you can get anywhere you want from
grinding I had a conversation with a
young man this morning we were going
over our schedule and based on the
schedule it didn't start till about 8 30
and they asked me why are you up at four
o'clock in the morning I'm getting up at
four because I don't have the resources
that other guy has I don't have a
connection you know what I'm saying my
parents didn't know anybody they weren't
part of any clubs right so I can beat
him though if I get up at three because
he's not getting up to six he ain't
getting up out there he's not getting up
at six he's not getting up at three so I
may not have his resources his
opportunities I mean I have his network
but if I grind I can beat him if I put
in the work I can catch up everything I
didn't have I can catch up with work and
that's what it means to me every
advantage that I want the currency to
get it is grind whatever your hand find
it do it with all your might and if I
could do it all my might I can catch the
dude that's got 10 years ahead look I
graduated in 12 years with a four-year
degree people used to laugh at me when
they got their four-year degree in four
years yeah I passed them not on sway I
didn't get them [ __ ] Swag yeah but I I
kept grinding and kept working Sway and
I caught the rabbit and I'm not quicker
than the rabbit but I caught the rabbit
because I didn't stop grinding so for me
that means if you willing to grind you
can have it you could be it you could do
whatever you want to do and nobody can
stop you if you had that grind hey it's
Evan carmichaelin I make these videos
because of my first business I struggled
to stay afloat I quit my business
partner and the thing that kept me going
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's live your best
believe life and get some incredible
motivation from the one and only Eric
Thomas enjoy
[Music]
rule number two is be disciplined every
single dude that I that I knew that was
about it about it in business they were
disciplined
right discipline
now this one right here is spooky
because I met a lot of men who were very
successful financially and they thought
because they had money they didn't have
to be disciplined and they end up losing
everything
damn they're losing everything they
weren't discipline right they became
alcoholics right
um sex addicts right
um didn't move with integrity that's the
one thing man I love about man y'all man
for real I'm telling y'all y'all got to
get with the right crew yo when y'all
hear them all talk about getting up and
working out they don't got nothing man I
promise y'all they don't have nothing to
do with life I ain't following no man
cause he got muscles
[Music]
I'm following them all because he got
muscles that come from discipline like I
promise you you call them all like your
mom the podcast you heard the podcast
your mom we want you to go see this they
try to you know what I'm saying get more
to see his billboard that's out there
trying to trick Maul like I can't do it
they like we need you to come right now
you're like this is my workout time
whatever you trying to show me
workout I gotta work out I'm trying to
get on this scale and be the same hot
the same uh weight I was when I was
coming out of college that's discipline
I was like you on a scale win he's like
every day I was like that's my that's my
problem how you been on the scale scale
my five years I'm just guessing I'm uh
189.
you know what I'm saying see I feel 189.
that's it the way my pants fit
189 all right let's go here's where me
and my wife get into it
so my wife was like first she said you
know
um you need more structure I was like in
my comments I don't need no more
struggles yeah structure ain't the
problem I'm gonna show you a whole bunch
of structure I said I got it sweetheart
I'm not willing to make the adjustment
but I don't run the type of company
where I want to get up every day and uh
what's the word I'm looking for see like
I don't want to get up every day and be
nobody boss
that make sense like I don't want to get
up and micromanage nobody right so the
challenge is at some point you're gonna
have to learn to be disciplined you're
gonna have to learn if you say You're
Gonna wake up at eight o'clock you're
gonna get up at eight o'clock no matter
how you feel like you got to be
disciplined and to get to the next level
of success you can't just have energy
when you got energy
I wanna make sure y'all catch that if
you're running a business and it's 365
then 365 you got you got to wake up
every day and you gotta go get it you
got why because if you don't hunt you
don't eat so here's the deal if you
hunted in January and you got enough
food for January you don't get to chill
February you got to get up in February
and go get enough food and so what a lot
of us do we aren't disciplined like
we're not self-motivated we're not
self-regulated we need outside people to
push up and that's not how the Creator
made us he didn't make us for all the
people to be over us so here's what I
told my wife sweetheart if another human
can tell you to get up and go to work
and do what you both do why can't you
pretend like if you you need another
human being be there be the human you be
that human if you need somebody to tell
you you need to lose 100 pounds be your
own voice to tell yourself you need to
don't go pay nobody fifty thousand
dollars to lose weight when you can do
it yourself and I'm not saying don't get
a person but at some point you got to
cut that person off why because if you
don't have personal discipline you'll
never get to the next level the next
level is not something that's far away
like Mall said the next level is
execution is not something that you know
we do it's something that we are and
most of us aren't disciplined
it's like you just go like you you drink
so you just go you you can't tell
yourself you know what I'm not mad at
you drink but you got a drink during the
weekday
by you drinking in the morning
before you go to work
you he gone now he's no longer with us
you're drinking an afternoon you're
drinking at night like I'm feeling you
like the drink but like all day every
day the weekend the weekday some of you
there think there are things you like
you have you had absolutely no control
you are like a slave to you you were a
slave to your personality you a slave to
some of your vices you a slave to some
of the things you like you a slave you
have absolutely no control and what I'm
telling you is the reason why we fast
from time to time is not that we have to
fast but at some point you gotta fast
because you gotta tell the flesh who's
in control
I'm in control you're not in control I
know you don't want to wake up you don't
have an option get up we trying to eat
there's a certain lifestyle we want you
think I want to get up at three o'clock
I put up a video Nikki I don't know what
happened I miscommunicated with Nikki
this morning I'm supposed to do the
videos at three or either I give them to
Nikki and then she'll do them in some
kind of way I don't know I don't know I
must have went to sleep woke up I ain't
know what time it was so I sent Nikki
what I wanted to say and I looked this
morning it was I sent it at 12 o'clock
at night midnight I thought I sent it
like 10 30 11. so when I got up it was
like three something our time and I was
like shoot I ain't put my video up
and I put the video up and I heard some
in the back of my mind say oh it's okay
you're on vacation
I said what
oh it's okay they'll understand I said a
little man who getting up at three to
read my stuff because he got somewhere
to go he don't know that I'm on vacation
he don't know that I'm here they don't
got nothing to do with his life he'll
know I'm in Mexico I ain't posting no
video he know how to slide this idea he
just know wherever he live in the world
at my three o'clock he uses that stuff
to do what he's going to do and he's
sitting there waiting
and an hour go by he like I guess he
ain't posting today listen to me it was
I was so late posted I almost didn't
want to post because I was embarrassed
I'm like I'm about an hour and 50
minutes two minutes off I'm two hours
off God said post it anyway that's
discipline
well I gotta post no videos I'm way past
posting videos posting videos was
something we did to blow up we blew up I
don't gotta post videos I don't post
videos to get motivated I don't post
videos get inspired I post videos to be
disciplined get your butt up and post a
video either you posted the night before
to Nikki or if she doesn't or will you
get up at three o'clock and you do it
that's discipline
there's a certain time frame that I'm
supposed to eat and certain things I
suppose he and then I eat after certain
time I'm making money I can eat whatever
I want but I'm trying to discipline
myself because there was a time I did
not discipline myself
you are not where you want to be not
because you need any more gifts you
don't need nothing else you need to
discipline yourself you need to learn to
tell you no you keep talking about
everybody else you can't tell no you
can't tell you no
you can't tell you stop you can't tell
you quit you can't tell you nothing you
got to get to a point where you're
disciplined and what separates The
Talented if everybody's talented if
everybody's equally gifted what
separates us is
discipline rule number three is
cultivate a winning mindset how do you
help people in that state cultivate a
different mindset is it by just pointing
out it's more effective is it something
else no it's you're already in pain get
a reward for it like you're already in
pain so at the end of the day you you
everything is already messed up so why
would you go through all that pain and
not get something for it like it doesn't
make sense like it doesn't make sense to
put all those hours in okay yeah it was
football but it doesn't make sense to
put all those hours in and not transfer
those hours to something else it doesn't
make sense not to recycle the pain and
get wealth or a successful life a
successful spouse like whatever have kid
whatever it is and so for me just going
through my go through I was like it
can't in here like bro it can't in here
I've worked too hard I I I've done I've
read the books I've gone to the
conferences I went to the classes I I
got the degrees like it can't end with
just life is going to deal me this hand
you know and so I truly feel and I don't
want to um promote gambling you know but
I gamble you know as a as a young adult
to make money and I and I watched guys
who had a royal flush lose because of
the Giddy and the excitement I'm like oh
he he got something you know I'm saying
okay take what I have and leave but I
also watch people who had nothing in
their head
with that poker face actually act as if
they had a royal flush and when and so I
learned early like yo it doesn't matter
if you grow up rich you still got to
play your hand it's not like life says
aren't you rich so you're not gonna have
any your parents will never get cancer
you know nobody in your family ever had
multiples gross like you'll never get
coveted you're rich it doesn't work like
that like you still have to do life
regardless of how you come into life and
I think some people feel well if you
come into life and everything is great
then that's the way you live life but no
it doesn't matter if you come in great
if you come in poorly it does not matter
you have to do life and if you're smart
you do like on your terms and you don't
let life make you do it on its terms
so you were homeless at 16 16 let's say
let's let's you read the book so
honestly 13. okay so that's when you
first started running away at 13. at 16
I kind of felt like I did this a couple
times I got this i got this I can't I
can't handle this you know so this is in
Detroit this is in Detroit it's not
exactly warm in the winter in Detroit
not at all so start leaving at 13 make
it pretty much permanent at 16.
you've got a lot of reasons to uh say
you know hand I've been dealt a bad hand
it's going to be difficult to play what
was the moment where you switched around
and decided you know what no this I'm
not going to tap out I'm not going to
let this be my future
so Church uh and not necessarily church
because I didn't grow up going to church
so it wasn't like the building ah it's
magical but the pastor there was a
military man I think he was an army man
you know so he had love but it was tough
love right and I'll never forget he
pulled me to the side and he gave me
something that I had never had before
and that was purpose he gave me a sense
of purpose and he said to me you are a
phenomenal speaker you gotta imagine I'm
like 16 almost 17 High School Dropout
coming to church smelling you know I'm
saying like I think it's so funny like
when people like your story I think
that's funny like man you have a
phenomenal story of like I wish this was
a story I just my life so I'm literally
coming to church when I come haven't
brushed my teeth I haven't taken a
shower I I smell based on whatever was
the last time I had an opportunity to
take a shower you know I'm in an extreme
relationship with my mom I'm on the
verge of getting kicked out of school I
have no bank account no credit cards and
this guy looks at me and says you're
going to be a phenomenal speaker like
you just you got that Genesee choir you
have something about and I'm thinking
what first of all nobody's ever said
anything like that to me before and
nobody's definitely said it in the state
that I'm in and so for me I'm I'm
pulling for strings for something in
life and this guy's like yo you got it
and I'm gonna do you have habit I
believe in you so much that I'm going to
use my name at my alma mater to get you
in school if you could just get a high
school diploma or a GED we're gonna get
you and so I don't know if it was him I
don't know if it was the words but this
sense of purpose and this identity like
yo I you're right I can't I I've never
seen him speaking in a way he saw it
before I got in trouble clowning in
class telling jokes but now he's saying
that what I do with Martin Luther King
with Malcolm X with Garvey what these
people do you can you have the ability
to do it and it was at that point I was
no longer I wasn't homeless and I don't
think I've ever said this before but I I
was I was homeless but I wasn't
discouraged at that point anymore like
it was the craziest thing I was
literally homeless practicing sermons I
was literally homeless visualizing being
in college you know at that time a
different world uh was on a spin-off you
know from The Cosby Show and like you
could actually I was like watching a
different world and seeing myself in the
cafeteria seeing myself in the dorm room
so this was the first time in my life
that I had this sense of light this
sense of purpose that yo I am not
worthless despite the fact that what I
considered my parents
they weren't married they did they
weren't in a long relationship like I
saw myself as an accident like these are
two kids you know what I'm saying uh I
don't know if it was in love I've been
lust I don't know what it was but I
there wasn't a nursery there wasn't a
book with names you know there wasn't a
baby shower you know I looked at myself
like I'm an accident this is the first
person who spoke to me and said really
you're not an accident you you you you
really were designed to be here and you
have a phenomenal gift that's going to
change the world and it was at that
point I'm in abandoned building seeing
myself speak I'm I'm I'm I'm in
abandoned buildings you know seeing
crowds I'm an abandoned building seeing
myself travel and it would it was at
that point I believe that this Eric
Thomas not this version I was definitely
the Eric Thomas 1.0 but it was at that
point that I began to see myself in the
way I'd never seen myself before rule
number four is have a phenomenal will I
want to hear about how you kind of got
to where you are now in your words
Venice the American dream you know they
say nowhere else you know but in America
and I was it was funny I was uh just
recently in an interview or had an
opportunity to do a luncheon with Warren
Buffett you know he was just saying that
you know this is the greatest country to
be born in this is the greatest time you
know to be born you know in this
particular uh country you know social
media you know economics just
opportunities so you know I'm the
American dream
um I represent you know with so many uh
people from my community represent
um you know a mom who had me out of
wedlock pregnant at 17 years old my
grandmother kicked her out not because
she didn't love her but my grandmother
kicked her out because she had 14 kids
and like two three bedroom houses one
bathroom fourteen kids and my
grandmother was like you know I just
can't afford to feed another mouth so
moms was homeless so when I say the
American dream you know you're talking
about
um not just my generation but my mother
um you know trying to finish high school
and you know getting a job in Detroit
working for Ford Motor Company so you
know the journey started with my mom and
I took it from you know my mom to an
entrepreneur but you know I eventually
dropped out of high school I was
homeless for about two and a half years
and you know through education I think
is where you know I I got my turn around
I'm not saying degrees that's not what
I'm talking about I'm talking about you
know going to school and really learning
how to identify my craft how to hone in
on my craft and how to sharpen that
craft and so I started a GED program
because I received my GED uh I was about
19 when I got my GED we dropped out of
high school yeah dropped out of high
school at 16 17. a couple years off a
couple a couple years ago a couple years
what was happening here those couple
years
um you know just trying to find myself
you know didn't know who my biological
father was at the time had never really
excelled academically
um I was a good athlete but because I
didn't keep my grades up you know I
couldn't play regularly so I was just
trying to find myself and I was
fortunate enough you know to get in a
good church with some good people who
helped Mentor me sent me to college
started dating a young lady at the time
who challenged me to go to school with
her and she's going to break up with me
you know so just some real good things
happen at the right time end up going to
college took me 12 long years and I
think the challenge was I didn't know
the code the rules you know I didn't
know the language of Academia and I
really had to humble myself you know it
really buckle down
um and that's what I did I started
working on my oratorical skills most
people won't believe it but I got to see
mine as you know in fundamentals of
speech you know
um you know but you know over time you
know I always tell people I got average
skill but I have phenomenal will you
know and so I just had to buckle down
and really ask myself what do I want to
do with the rest of my life and so I
think it was a GED program I did and
this may sound real simple to people but
I think the GED gave me purpose you know
and in that purpose I found my passion
like I finally found something that
nobody had to force me to do uh
something that I woke up to every day I
loved it I loved studying the books I
loved the information I love working
with students you know I would spend the
first five ten minutes reading a
motivational piece and then like kind of
elaborating on that piece and I just
fell in love with teaching I fell in
love with that environment I found that
I had a way to connect with people that
was you know that was rare uh and so
from there I went back to school took 12
years but got a degree in business then
went to Michigan State Masters and PhD
in education and just really worked on
my gift I realized that all of us are
born with a gift but you gotta hone it
you know it's just not you're not going
to become great and we talk about the
school of greatness you know we talk
about
um you know greatness is upon you and I
realize that my gift wasn't going to
create itself my gift wasn't going to
nurture itself my gift wasn't going to
perfect itself that was something I had
to do and so man and before you know it
we did a video that went viral I think
it's got over 50 million hits now and we
turn our passion into unprofit man yeah
I love it to turn our passion into
problems if you want to succeed as bad
as you want to breathe then you'll be
successful absolutely yeah that's a good
one and that's been used you know the
audio of that I've been using like
hundreds of videos that get you know 20
50 million views alone alone I love the
football the football ones yeah yeah
yeah it's a great little man yeah like
put me back at school and coaches yeah
but I was like maybe if I would have
taken my shirt off it would have blew up
early but I doubt that died seriously
yeah hilarious man yeah so is it would
you say that one speech when was that
speech uh that speech was back in like
2008 2009 did you say there was a big
game changer for you I mean
I wouldn't say the world has said it you
know and you know what's so funny and
this is why I tell people
you know just do what you do you know so
many people are what I call
um they're gang watching they're
scoreboard watching like every play
they're looking up to see where they are
you know and I mean you can't you you
can't scoreboard watch and play the game
at the same time no you got to play the
game you know they're so worried about
all right is this gonna be my year is
this gonna like they spend so much time
concentrating on when the big one is
gonna happen that the big one never
happens because you can't you can't
chase two rabbits if you chase two
rabbits you're not gonna catch either
one so for us it was an accident we
didn't we didn't plan on doing it I was
in a room going off on a group of
students because they had an opportunity
of a lifetime and they weren't taking
advantage of it some guy just happened
to have a video camera just happened to
put the mic on me just happened to use
it for his thesis and let me say this he
never ever used it for his thesis he
never used it friend of mine's like yo
what you do with that video you did two
years ago he was like well I still have
it he's like okay give it to me I'm
gonna put it up on YouTube away there
and not YouTube for The World YouTube
because that was a a place to house your
videos
that was the only reason you just won
the house content you know and I end up
leaving my job at Michigan State I
thought it was time to go do you know my
own thing and I promise you two or three
months after I left it went viral it was
literally online for years and didn't
have any real traction and then when I
left my job and I said this is it I
can't explain it but it began to go
viral the one in the classroom and then
a year or so later Giovanni's also
started to go viral and he told me
Giovanni said yeah the football guy said
he just did it so Scouts in the NFL
could see it right and so somebody stole
it from off of the internet and they put
it up put the audio over yeah and boom
yeah unbelievable is he playing in the
league right now he didn't make it to
the lead so so hey what does that tell
you about to leave right this guy to me
I thought you could play in the league
he went to Canada and played for a
minute yeah and um but for whatever
reason you know he hasn't given up on
his dreams uh playing in the league but
it just goes to show you that the league
is one percent of the greatest talent in
the world the greatest yeah yeah also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is be humble you
gotta be humble you know and I think too
many of us who've been been blessed like
we've been blessing people watch us and
don't see the humility like they would
prefer to see you know the confidence in
us you know the passion and Overlook
like the humility but when you're humble
that's how you see things that other
people don't see like when you're humble
you see you're a running water you know
I'm saying I've been to other countries
where they don't have running water you
know um you know we all have a roof
already this is a different type of roof
yes you know what I'm saying but but you
can look at this every day and see the
water and just go like yo it's a gift
because how many people have tried to do
the exact same thing you've tried to do
in the exact same way you try to do it
and it didn't end up like this so I wake
up every day like you know e you've been
married 20. somebody you've been married
almost 28 years like somebody took a
chance on you you know I'm saying and
I'm being real like her mom was like
don't do it her father was like don't do
it like what does he have he doesn't
have anything that's a gift when
somebody loves you when you don't have
absolutely anything and then now it's a
gift to be with somebody who's not with
me because I'm an E.T the hip-hop
preacher but really has been with me
like in the good the bad the ugly so I
know this is my my ride or die so I
think gifts are all around us but some
people aren't humble enough to say yeah
I did work for this one but this one
let's just be honest yeah I didn't work
for this one yeah this was a gift from
God this was given to me yeah and I and
I got to be humble and be grateful rule
number six is give back we were talking
about in the beginning you know we can
make all the money we want get the cars
the Jets or whatever and have the fancy
things but
one's enough enough like before you want
to start making an impact and I feel
like everything that I do and we do it's
like if it's not giving back in some way
then what's the point yeah if it's just
for me or just for us alone yeah and
it's not to serve people in a bigger way
like we're doing something wrong yeah
let me tell you man last night you're
talking about DD and I've been married
26 years together 30 and we check in
last night knowing what's going on today
and just to be able to hold each other
you know as for me I'm like no child
yeah education There's No Child Left
Behind and I'm sitting here like yo I'm
with my my high school sweetheart like
we made it through everything and we're
doing this thing together you know my
son calls me this morning for worship
you know he's like Dad I just want to
get the day started a couple players in
the car and we're doing our thing and
I'm like yo I didn't have to leave my
wife or my kids Behind like we're all
together I'm with the team eating
breakfast I'm like yo we didn't lose we
didn't lose you know and then you're in
the airport and then somebody is hugging
you and crying I'm like yo we're able
we're taking everybody with us you know
it's like the LeBron commercial in
Cleveland when he's starting to work out
and then before you see it like
everybody's running before his thousands
of people with LeBron I'm like that's
how we feel Nike hasn't asked us to do
that particular commercial yeah you know
but that's what we're doing like it's
people who are following us in every
city now we got breathe University there
are people all over the world they're on
this movement of this being phenomenal
so they're not forgotten they're on this
they're on this for real the school of
greatness like they're really about
being great and it's not us alone it's
it's all of us together man so it's just
been sweet not getting to the top and
like you're by yourself but I've gotten
to the top and all these people are
still coming with us so it's just it's
what you say is money okay yeah you do
need that you need resources but it's
not about the money the money is a tool
to help you accomplish that goal you're
trying to accomplish rule number seven
is dominate you ain't gonna forget my
name when I die my videos will continue
to go on I dominate this doggone thing I
ain't just here speaking I dominate
where I go stuff happened I dominate if
you gonna win if they gonna put your
name in the number up there you just
can't play this game cause there are
other teams that want to do exactly what
you got to do so what you got to do in
practice is one two three in practice
not in the field that's just some of
y'all that's your problem you think that
you can dominate when the lights come on
if you can't dominate in practice you
can't dominate when the lights come on I
get up every morning at three o'clock I
dominated three o'clock in the morning I
dominate with everybody sleep I
dominated four in the morning six in the
morning hey I go back to bed why cause
y'all just getting up
I dominate in the dark I dominate when
nobody sees me
that's why I dominate in the light
because I dominate in the dark on three
one two three I gotta get that in your
head one two three one two three if you
can dominate the numbers gonna say 20
22.
every single team you play
now here's the deal I grew up and again
I'm not trying to be disrespectful we
all got our opinion I know I'm from
Chicago so I might be biased with
Michael Jordan I'm just like I'm MJ all
day
I hear other people compare themselves I
said let me tell you something MJ it
wasn't no game seven what does that mean
he did what
didn't matter if he was in Utah he was
in Chicago if he was in Wisconsin like
but bucks it didn't matter what Mike's
mentality was whoever we play I'm gonna
dominate these individuals that's what
I'm gonna do now I'm not trying to be
disrespectful so I'm not gonna say no
other name because I don't want y'all to
be like I don't want to hear what my man
got to say but there are other guys who
are good who considered great they go to
game seven and they take the last second
for them to win the game Mike was like
three feet no come back another three
Peak dominated and so I need y'all do me
a huge favor like I need you to eat
sleep breathe dominate
it doesn't matter how good or bad they
are we're not playing to the level of
our competition no more we're not we're
not even playing sometimes we good
sometimes we great we gonna go out there
on three y'all we gonna do what this
year one two three one two three I'm
gonna make you say it for real for real
before I get out of here some of y'all
own it some of y'all like one two three
one two three every single practice
every in film you gonna dominate you're
gonna look at filming the way they don't
look at film you're gonna practice in
the way they don't cry you go everything
you do is gonna be in a way that nobody
else does
because the ultimate goal is to win
every film session every practice every
game
and then our ultimate goal this year is
to finish on top and win to what
let's go let's not go there let's not we
don't go that far yet let's let's back
it up so we're gonna win in film
sessions how many already women film
sets let me hit dominate one two three
and film I'm talking about one two three
learning to plays dominates I
listening to coach paying attention
being locked in and focused one two
three we dominating field room first
then we dominating the practice one two
three then when we play the game we go
one two three
and each game we're going what does it
matter which team it is no come on does
it matter which team you think it
matters to your mama sitting out there
which team you think it matters to your
daddy you think your grandma care who
you playing let's do it very closely I
take it personal when I do what I do I
don't ever want my mom to come to hear
me speak and walk away and go bye that
wasn't his best
do me a huge favor when your mom and
that stand please don't embarrass her
don't make her you know how long that
walk is when you lose
anybody know how long that walk is when
you lose
you know your mind went got her hair
done grandma got suited up okay watch
again you're not alone that walk in I
don't care who we playing we go one two
three I don't care who we going up
against one two three
how many y'all raise your hand your mama
deserve your mama deserved for you to go
ahead and win it all this year let me
see yeah she deserves how many are hands
down every game she come to she deserves
to see you win let me see him how many
of y'all Mama sacrifice for y'all when
you were young and took you all to
practice and didn't go to work and
couldn't do some of the stuff she wanted
to do because she put you in this
situation raise your hand let me see
your head how many of y'all think your
mama deserve
what's the first one so we're gonna win
each game and the first thing we're
gonna win is the what
good when in practice after that
film room after that
good after that
I just want y'all think about it what
division you in
so you got to win the what
on one side then you got to Win It On Up
so the first one we gonna win is the SEC
what then we're gonna win uh
the champion we gotta win the
championship then we're gonna go to the
playoffs then we gonna win the playoffs
then we're gonna go to the you can't win
it if you can't see it
gotta see each one division you got to
see yourself winning in practice you
gotta see yourself winning the game the
SEC East you gotta see yourself then the
championship you gotta see yourself then
the playoffs you gotta see yourself wake
up every single day I was here before I
was here
I was up this morning here I've been
here before I was in this spot right
here I was talking from right here I
envisioned it I saw it already
but I see it before it happened you got
a one two three uh come on one two three
one two three all right write this down
real quick if you got something to write
with number one discipline
discipline means that you dominate when
you feel like it and you dominate when
you don't feel like it and can I be
honest with y'all if you discipline
yourself enough somebody said to me E.T
when you get up at three o'clock in the
morning are there days you don't feel
like it I'm talking about less than one
percent I've been doing it so long now
I've been getting up so early for so
long I've dominated my sleep pattern
I've dominated my laziness I've
dominated procrastination I've dominated
so much that when I get up at three
o'clock in the morning CJ said it don't
matter if we are in Russia it don't
matter if we are in Germany it don't
matter if we're in Australia it don't
matter if we're in Dubai my body just
clicking three o'clock and went
discipline I don't even gotta hit an
alarm clock my body like yo E 230 get up
e245 one two three discipline one two
three one two three discipline is you do
it so long and so hard and you're so
passionate about it that even when you
don't feel like it you still operated
the highest level Michael Jordan they
call it the flu game he still scored
more than the average dude with the flu
because your body will get so accustomed
to being great that even when you got
the flu you were
I'll say it one more time even when you
got the flu and you gotta you got the
flu and you playing other Champions you
still score more than they score because
you've learned how to you learn how to
you've learned how to I dominate where I
go stuff happens I dominate if you're
gonna win if they gonna put your name in
the number up there what you got to do
in practice is one two three in practice
rule number eight is use your gift let's
roll this is a command I know I got some
religious folks in here but I'm gonna
say something to you Exodus Exodus is
not the first Commandments so for those
of you who on Exodus 20 that's not the
first commandment that's the one that's
the one that when you mess up that's the
one where you get on punishment
that's the one where you get on this was
the first one
it was the first command that we were
given
and God blessed them
and said unto them be fruitful
multiply replenish the Earth and subdue
it and have dominion
over the fish of the sea over the fall
of the air over every living thing that
move upon the face of Earth so I'm just
gonna break this down this is what this
is the one percent y'all
that's the one percent just in case you
didn't know it just the one percent what
is the one percent now the first thing
he did was he blessed them and what is
that CJ say you got a superpower but the
problem with most humans is we don't
want the superpower God gave us
I went to Oakwood I promise y'all now
most of y'all know Brian McKnight he was
uh at the University and he could sing
but he wasn't the best singer at the at
the University
watch this though it was crazy that you
had kids who could play the piano who
could sing who could do a lot of stuff
and guess what they were just like I'm
not doing it
I came from the hood I'm like you're
playing the piano
first of all from the hood the only
people play piano from the hood was your
parents had to have bread and they
didn't live in our neighborhoods that
was like your cousin who mine was a
doctor and they would come and visit and
they knew how to play the piano somebody
had money College I went to all the kids
knew how to play the piano everybody
could say
but what was crazy was they could sing
but they didn't want to do it
I'm like how you know how to do
something and you don't do it like
that's odd to me you know how to do
something and you not I people who were
smart was like yo I'm just not feeling
College how you that smart and you ain't
you not feeling it I'm like bro I can't
hardly read and write and I'm up in this
joint
I'm struggling in this Joy you know I'm
saying I'm trying my hardest to
understand what I just read and you can
literally read you can comprehend you
have been blessed with a beautiful mind
and you just woke up and was like God I
ain't feeling it
I'm good I'm grateful for the five gifts
but I'm only on one you can keep the
other four
this the one I like are you hearing me
so when we first are born we he blessed
them I was blessed with this this thing
that used to get me in trouble in school
has now changed millions of people's
lives when I was born I was given this
and God said you can use it however you
want it but if you use it the way I tell
you to use it
are you not hearing what I'm saying I'm
a high school dropout I did not get this
when I got my PhD
God didn't go he finally got his pH you
didn't give him the voice
we finally got it he's ready now he got
his GED give him the voice God gave me
the voice when I was a clown when I was
acting a fool you got your gift from
birth and the reason why you struggling
is because God gave you something and
you're doing the opposite of what he
gave you
he said look this is what I'm gonna do
for him I'm gonna bless him and if
that's not enough you're like okay
listen to me that's what I love for own
religious folks like this is why I had a
problem I kept reading this because all
I was reading before was the Ten
Commandments
Ten Commandments got a different
connotation to them that's again when
you're on punishment
thou shall not
remember this like like that's the kind
of remember this that's the kind of
stuff when somebody tell you to remember
something I mean you forgot
somebody tell you to remember something
you ain't forget thou shall not thou
shall not that's not got a negative
connotation I'm good on that I'm going
with this one because if you do what
you're supposed to do you're not gonna
have to worry about
no no listen to me very closely I'm not
trying to be disrespectful but I don't
need the Ten Commandments why because I
don't have no other gods before God's
he ain't talking to me he talking to
somebody that got some other guy before
him he's not talking to me I don't I
wake up at three o'clock in the morning
the first person I talk to was God an
hour out I ain't got no other gods
before God that's for somebody else I'm
not dishonoring my parents I send them
away every winter they stay in
California as long as they want to I'm
not dishonoring I'm not lying no more
that's not for me this is for me and God
blessed them I'm the number one
motivational speaker in the world and
God bless them and everything our
company touch is blessed and God blessed
them
that's the one percent life rule number
nine is be obsessed with the process
when I got my GED I felt like I was on
top of the world I had done it all I got
my GED I did what my father didn't do I
deal with my grandfather didn't do I got
my GED I was on top of the world
and when I went to Oakwood College I got
kicked out on academic probation and I
didn't bother me one bit why because I
was the first one in my family to go to
college
I sat in a college classroom and I had
the experience nobody in my family had
ever graduated from college up to that
point so it wasn't even that deep to me
why because nobody had ever done it I
was just geeked that I that I was the
first one to make it happen that I could
actually say I sat in a class and I knew
what the classroom was like I actually
took tests I ate at the cafeteria I
slept in the dorm room like I felt it
watch this very closely what was so
crazy was when God saw this right before
I even saw this right and so he said to
me not only are you going to go back to
school you're going to get a PhD you
just don't know about it
but what I'm going to do with the
four-year degree with the master's
degree and the PHD what I'm going to do
for you is what I did for Inky it's not
about school it's about the process
and so I need you to wake up every
morning at three o'clock and pray this
has nothing to do with just praying I
want you to become obsessed with the
process and the reason why some of you
will never get to where God would have
you to get to you'll never get to where
you want to and I'm talking about true
fulfillment and let me tell you
something I've had money it don't don't
let them fool you for those of you who
run up behind it I promise you you can
have it and still not be happy and so
when I got my GED I thought I was on top
of the world and God says you have no
idea son how I'm gonna use you to change
this world you have no idea so because
you have no idea because the dream is
too deep for you
it's too rich for you you could never
understand it as a 17 year old as a 21
year old as a 30 year old what I'm going
to do is put you in school so we can
ignite the process because nothing else
happens until the process happens so the
inky Johnson we see today began at seven
years old and your problem is your
dreams are you are no closer to your
dreams because your process hadn't
started
[Music]
you wake up every single day and you
chasing money you wake up every single
day and you chasing stuff you wake up
every single day you chasing this
business and that business in this
business and you have not gotten
yourself to the point yet where you are
waking up to the process and I would
wake up and I would have to write and it
would break me and I would have to read
and it would break me
I was on my way here today my son sent
me some and unfortunately he's sitting
in a way where it's small I'm trying to
lift it up and I'm going back and forth
and I'm reading and my wife is like oh
you're reading is killing me
I could feel her spirit I'm like it's
okay I still gotta do it though because
the point of this joke is fire and so I
gotta give it to you normally what I
would do is I would read it once or
twice on my own and then come into
people's presence and read it
so when I was in school and it was
feeling uncomfortable God was like son
it's okay that it's feeling
uncomfortable this is a part of the
process I'm grinding you I'm stripping
you I'm molding you so when you finally
get to be the number one motivational
speaker in the world I don't have to
strip you down because I've already
strip you and for many of you your
stripping process has not happened
because you're about money and really
not about the dream
you're not really about the dream you're
not really about that life because when
God's beginning to strip you like Inky
said as he begins to strip you you run
when he starts to prove you
I say you pruning me I got a GED you
pruning me I ain't on the Block No More
You pruning me I'm married now you
pruning me I'm back in school you pruned
me I ain't in the hood No More what are
you doing I'm doing what you telling me
to do he said that's why I'm pruning you
because I don't prune things that don't
bear fruit
I don't prune things that don't bear
fruit I prune things to bear fruit why
so I can get more out of it and you want
to stop at the four-year degree you have
no idea son this is not about you you
selfish this has nothing to do with you
you ain't great this has nothing to do
with you I'm using you for my purpose
and my will and we got a whole lot more
stripping to do
so number one leave the doggone dream
alone that's not your business
you don't know how long you're gonna be
alive
you have no idea what condition you're
gonna be in a year or two from now the
dream is not your business but the
process is
and so I want you to look at the next 24
hours of your life the next week of your
life the next month of your life and I
want you to wake up every single day and
I need you to have a process Inky had a
process
icky did the same thing every single day
eight years old nine years old 10 years
old 11 years old high school football
college football he did the exact same
thing guys watch this watch this watch
this I read this story y'all it blew my
mind he lost everything in one day that
he had worked for his whole life but in
fact he didn't lose anything because
what he thought he was supposed to have
wasn't what he was supposed to have
anyway
and many of you at the point of being
broken you shatter and Rule Number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is know what you want you
can't dangle something in front of my
face that's I don't want that and many
of you are taking anything because you
don't know what you want and so if I can
do one thing for you when you leave this
room I don't want nothing from you but
for you to leave this room and know what
you want what do you want in your
marriage what do you want with your son
and your daughter what do you want in
your health what do you want financially
like how much money do you want to make
a year what do you want to drive how do
you want to live stop just waking up
like an accident what do you want and
then once you find out what you want
spend the rest of your natural life
waking up and going after it the reason
why I speak with so much passion E.T why
do you speak with so so much Authority
because I'm talking about my life not
something that I read I ate out of trash
cans
I had no business eating out of trash
cans I lived in abandoned buildings I
had no business living in abandoned
buildings
but E.T your daddy wasn't in your life
your mom was a teenage mother you you
grew up come on eat look at your search
that's not an excuse there's no excuse
for not living up to your fullest
potential no excuse
I told you I didn't get a new Daddy I
didn't get a new mama what changed I
changed and I stopped being a victim I
stopped saying I've got to wait for good
things to happen to me and I said I'm
gonna grind I'm going to fight I'm going
to work I'm going to press short I'm
going to learn I'm going to do
everything in my power every single day
I'm going to do everything in my power
to become a Victor and not a victim now
let me say this before I move forward
and I can't explain it but you better
feel me winners win and losers lose
I can't explain it any better than that
I don't know how it happens but winners
win and if you create a culture of
losing if you keep being a victim if you
keep letting losing happen to you if you
keep letting people do you and treat you
any kind of way it's going to become a
culture let me tell y'all
I'm not I'm not from New Zealand guys
come on listen to me very closely I'm
not from New Zealand but I know about
let me say it this way so I can help you
I know about what team
I'm not I've never seen it I've never
seen all blacks I play a day in my life
I've never been to the stadium where's
the stadium
help me out where's the stadium okay I'm
going to see right you see you right
there I've never been to the stadium you
like Eric the stadium that's Hobbit that
way Eric that's not the stadium the
stadium is this way I've never been
there a day in my life and if you watch
some of my videos I have all blocked in
my videos why cause they're what
they're winners
we go to school for all these years and
they never really show us the importance
of dreaming
right I look at school and I'm like yo
the way school is designed is it's
designing you to be prepared to work for
somebody else and I'm not even upset
with that but there's little of you that
you get right y'all got to work with me
because this is deep right so I said to
my son I said to my son son I got to ask
you a question like and I'm being
serious I said Do you believe you
created yourself
he was like what I was like do you
believe you created yourself he said no
I said do you believe there's a Creator
he said of course I do I said don't do
that don't don't do the dad thing
because you know who I am and you know
like I'm about that life like don't
answer like I'm asking you for real for
real you owe me nothing this is you do
you believe that there's something out
here that's bigger than you
he said of course I do dad
I said Do you believe as a human being
not in a braggadocious way but that you
are the greatest level of all creation
and he's like you mean like over a deer
I was like yeah dear
he'll be like you mean better than the
ego I'm like yeah like an eagle he was
like of course because we can make
decisions we can do things I said okay
okay I just want to go back again you
don't believe you were created he said
no but you believe there's a higher
power he was like yeah and and I said
okay okay okay you believe it's a human
you powerful he was like of course words
I say so as a human do you believe you
were just born to be in a relationship
have sex and have money and buy stuff
he was like um
no I guess it's something bigger than
that Dad it's like I guess the other
thing is a call and I said well if you
believe that why have you never gone
after your calling
why you spend so much time worrying
about a relationship why you spend so
much time son worried about money and
cars and stuff if you really believe
what you just told me that as a human is
something greater than that then why
aren't you on that he was like I don't
know I said because here's a trick son
if you get this and that you still might
not get you
I'm just being real with the Montage I
think it's a fabulous place it's great
but I didn't walk in there like ah
like it was really the mountains that
made me go whoa it was really when I saw
the birds flying out how I was like
unbelievable it wasn't really the room
that I was like this is the great as a
matter of fact the guy was getting on my
nerve I guess when you pay money to go
there they got to try to do the old
personable thing I'm like bro bro I'm on
the call please just give me the keys so
I can go to my room and if I have some
problems when I get to my room I will
call you so I'm having a conversation
with my son saying son do me a huge
favor don't go after low-hanging fruits
here's the deal if you get to the top of
the tree all the fruit from the bottom
at the top is going to be there son
so I don't need you focusing on cars and
money and stuff you're gonna get that I
need you to focus on why you were born
in the first place why are you here on
Earth for this particular time what are
you doing here
anybody can buy a car son of animals get
in relationships animals have sex and
have kids it's Sons it's got to be
deeper than that if you're higher than
humans then while you're here on Earth
you got to do more than what animals do
and so when they talked about dreams and
Legacy I was like yo people don't get it
write this down your DNA is in your
dream
your DNA is in your dream so so it was
funny I was walking with CJ father the
other day and we were talking and I
promised y'all like every single time we
talk I don't care when it is I don't
care how long we talk we always talk
about the relationship he had with his
father and and I know that the impact
that it had on his kid as a listen to me
his DNA his his dream his DNA is family
like that's all he cared about is his
son like we when we go out I never saw
him dress like a certain way like he's
never like hold on E I got to get the
polo shirt and every time I talk to him
it's the same thing his DNA his dream
his DNA his kids has formed his life it
is formed who he is as a man and most of
y'all are chasing stuff you don't
realize your dreams are so important
because your DNA who you are as a person
is wrapped up in your dreams and what
this world has done to you is take that
from you because they know if you know
who you're Dr who you are and you get
your drink you're probably not gonna
work for most of them
you're probably not gonna do most of the
dumb stuff you do it's like for real if
you knew who you if you knew your dreams
and you knew and you followed your
dreams you followed your DNA most of you
probably would have never been on drugs
I've never met a person before who knew
who they were and was on drugs it's
important for me to let you know that
you are powerful beyond measure listen
to me I told you last week because
Perhaps Perhaps I don't know your daddy
wasn't in your life Your Mother wasn't
in your life I don't know you didn't
have a mentor I don't know but you you
may have never heard someone look you in
your eye look you in your soul and tell
you that you not only matter you're
powerful and you are powerful beyond
measure but listen to me that's just no
one is half the battle that is not
enough to know it's not enough to know
now I need you to apply so I'm gonna
give you three quick principles that and
I wanna when this thing is over I'm
telling you I want you to take your life
to a whole other level I want you not
only to understand you matter I want you
to go in that mirror and say I'm I
matter so so so the first story I'm
gonna tell you right because I don't
know if if you like me right but I
remember as a business when we got our
first credit card excited we had a
pretty nice limit on there so we could
get our products and we could travel we
could get our t-shirts the whole night
but it was it was weird when we first
got the card I don't know if you ever
seen that strip before that's right you
matter you're powerful beyond measure
you know what I'm talking about you got
the card right limit if we had a nice
size limit we had the money to do what
we needed to do to take this this
ministry to a whole other level right
but when we got the card what we
discovered was although the money was in
the bank before we could get the money
before we could use the money we had to
activate the car that's right we had to
call that number and say yes we agree
are you hear what I'm telling you I'm
telling you that look you can't activate
life you can't begin to experience life
in the way you want to experience you
can't have it you can't be it you can't
do it until you activate it and yes it's
all in there all your gifts all your
talents all your everything you need to
do to be what you've been called to do
what you've been birthed to do you can't
do until you activate it until you
recognize you matter everything about
you is great but the problem is you have
consciously chosen to be average I get
it I get it like innately innately
everything about you is great everything
about you is phenomenal but you've
consciously made a decision to be
average you are average in school you're
average at your workplace like
everything you do is average and not
because it's average but because you
made a decision you made a choice to be
average why because the people around
you are average or maybe you grew up in
an average environment or went to an
average school or you work for an
average company and so you've decided
you've decided to go against who you are
you've decided to go against who you are
all right all right so I get it watch
this this is deep so so that's why you
go to the basketball games I got it now
that's why you spent hours watching your
favorite athlete right right because
when you watch them you watch them it's
something about you that's attracted to
that greatness because there's something
in you that's great so that's why you
watch them because it's easier to watch
him reach greatness than it is for you
to put in sweat Blood and Tears to
become great that's why you that's why I
got it now that's why you buy all the
magazines and you're looking at home
girl on the magazine right I got it now
because it's easier to look at her and
and get motivated and pumped up and you
feel something inside what do you feel
you feel that greatness and that
phenomenal you stirring up that's why
that's why you put those headphones on
and you just shut the whole world out
and you listen to your favorite artist
you're listening to them sing or you're
listening to them rap and deep down
inside you hurt when you listen because
it should be you I got it now I
understand now you are attracted to
greatness because greatness is all in
you but it's easier to watch greatness
it's easier to go see greatness than it
is to put in the time to put in the
energy to to discipline yourself to
sacrifice it's easier and so that's why
you average and so you frustrated
because you're not living like you
should live no you don't have what you
should have you're not being who you
should be and so that's why you you
don't want to wake up in the morning
that's why you pissed off with Monday
because Monday is the day that you're
supposed to go mole in shape and create
your greatness that's why you like
Friday I get it because Friday you get
to chill you don't have to face yourself
on Friday you don't have to face
yourself on Saturday on Sunday that's
the day that everybody is partying
everybody's drunk everybody gets to
forget that they didn't become who they
were supposed to come during the week
that's why I get it now but I challenge
you listen to me I challenge you why do
I because I know you can't I know listen
to me some of you you're not even in the
game can you do me a favor get in the
game one thing that bothers me like
right now in life
you know life would be so great for me
man I promise you if I could fix this
one thing
but my biggest challenge
is he said the fixed mindset you know
the growth mindset is that I gotta hang
with people that don't have my mindset
man it's just so it's just so hard man
you know because you know people think
you bougie I'm not trying to be bougie
you know but a lot of my people that I
love
I I isolate myself I spend time you know
away from a lot of people and it's like
yo I ain't mad at y'all but I want to
win 82 games man I want to win 82 games
I want to win every playoff game I want
to sweep every dog on team I want to win
the doggone championship and you get
with people who make it to the league if
they make it and that's enough for them
and a lot of people like you know my I
had a conversation with my boy called me
the other day and it just was so rough
you know because it was like yo I ain't
trying to leave none of y'all
but I ain't trying to die being with
y'all you know what I'm saying like and
I got to make what a lot of humans don't
realize I got to make so many sacrifices
to be with you you know what I'm saying
and it ain't and it ain't like I'm
trying to be better than you or I'm a
bad dude but like let's just be real
Josh we staying at the Montage you know
I'm saying my girl was like we spent a
lot like DD sit down like she was like
it cost for three days however long we
staying at 10 grand I'm like no question
no so it ain't like I got nothing
against nobody Josh but when I travel I
don't want to be at the Holiday Inn
Express yeah no question I did that
already bro I paid my dues I stayed I
stayed in the motel six bruh I was in
the La Quinta when I first started
speaking with you you feel me when I and
I started when I was 19. bruh we was
driving 10 12 hours 16 hours I want to
do that in 47. and the fact that you
didn't grow or you you want to stay
where you are I'm not mad at you but I
get I get angry with people because you
you trying to make me feel bad because I
I want to grow bro like I wake up every
day and I want to be better than what I
was the day before so if I go to a
restaurant and I want to I want eggs bro
I went to a restaurant the other day it
was like three o'clock in the afternoon
but I was at one of them hotels where
they own no we don't serve eggs yeah
they're not on that they like we here
for you that's the difference in the
hotel Holiday Inn Express they telling
me we'll serve that we only serve that
from 6 to 11. the Montage they like you
won't scrambled eggs with cheese okay
how many eggs you want okay what else do
you eat well I'm I eat the soy we got
soy too we got everything and don't come
downstairs bring it up we'll bring it up
so I just want to say you know for real
man that's the one thing in my life
right now
that that if I had a magic wand I would
fix I want to be with everybody yeah but
I can't be around average and you can't
be mad at me because I don't it's like
what Jamal saying I want to get property
that's what he does I don't want to be
around people who don't want to take
risks yeah not because I'm mad at you
but you you bottling me up yeah you
making me not right I want to fly this
is what's so crazy like even as I stand
here like I can't believe I'm in
Columbus Ohio like I can't believe I'm
with Lewis house like I can't believe I
went to some of the greatness like guys
I was out
I was just homeless like I was just
literally sleeping in abandoned
buildings I was literally just thinking
about committing suicide right and so so
what happened was I was introduced I was
probably about 16 almost 17 and I was
introduced to a pastor a friend of
mine's took me to church with him and it
was the oddest thing I went to church
maybe about three or four times and I
didn't grow up in church so I wasn't
really there for like the religious
aspect of it but this was my best friend
and this is where he went regularly
right and and I loved it it kind of
reminds me of this Summit you know it
was a lot of positive people right first
time in my life being in an environment
with just positivity right they would
sing and the pastor would speak and we'd
have a dinner after every church I think
that's probably why I went because it
was like a meal really you know I'm
saying when you homeless and your high
school dropout you eating out a trash
can like a hot meal is just unbelievable
right that's why I'm gonna fool you to
this day right and so but I'll never
forget he would say to me you know maybe
maybe three or four weeks into going
regularly you know he said to me kid
what are you doing with your life and
I'm like what does that mean exactly
he's like what's your goals what's your
dreams like I don't have any goals any
dreams like my biological father wasn't
in my life my mom got pregnant with me
at 17 years old like I don't come from
what you know what what we call like the
Ola Mills experience you know I'm not
like you know my great-grandfather a
picture with my grandfather and my
father and me like I don't I don't know
what I want to do and I remember maybe
about the second month of coming to
church he would say to me he'd say you
know what you need to get your GED and
you need to go to college
and I was like what
like don't you know I'm living like I'm
living in abandoned buildings like I'm
working at McDonald's and I'm eating
McDonald's like I like my mother is 7 17
when she had me she didn't finish well
she barely finished high school she
didn't go to college my Grandma had 14
kids none of them went to college like
we don't do college
you know and it was just so weird this
is why you need to be in this type of
environment because this environment
activates and give you permission to do
I'm sorry I get excited because I'm not
supposed to be on the stage listen to me
I was literally homeless I was coming to
church not really taking showers I
wasn't brushing my teeth and this God
looked at me and said you need to get
your GED you need to leave Detroit I'm
going to send you to college because
greatness is upon you
guys that that's why this environment is
so important because what he did was he
allowed me to see who I was before I
could really see who I was
and he saw guys I just we just buried
him about four weeks ago and and he saw
something in me like like everybody in
the world now says like yo E.T I watch
your video and this happened and I have
and E.T you know I get inspired I was 16
17 years old I had never spoken a day in
my life and this guy saw it like he saw
something to me that I didn't see and he
gave me permission to be where other
people said I couldn't be he gave me
permission to believe I was great he
gave me permission to think I could
change the world he gave me permission
to start something that had never
started in my family before he gave me
permission to say I am I am I am
he gave me permission to say I am
brilliant
uh yeah I might be different but I am
brilliant yep I might be loud but I am
special
he gave me permission and so the first
thing I want you to do today is I want
you to keep saying to yourself I am I am
I am I am and for those of you who
hadn't quite started yet I am and for
those of you who gotten started I am why
because I can't believe that I started
with a GED and that GED turned into a
four-year degree took me 12 years guys
it took me 12 years but Pastor would
keep telling me you are brilliant you
are special Eric yes you're different
and yes you're not doing it to
traditional route but greatness is upon
you you got to keep going you got to
keep going you got to keep going in the
12 years to get the four-year degree
turn into a master's degree
and the Master's Degree turned into a
PhD God I can't believe it
I went from being a High School Dropout
from being homeless living in abandoned
buildings to eating out of trash cans to
Dr Eric Thomas to writing six books guys
are you here what I'm saying today stop
playing small and start playing big
because I am people say why you still
getting up so early in the morning three
o'clock because I was on the I was on
the beach with my wife not too long ago
we was holding hands walking up the
beach and my wife said I know it's hard
for me to quit my job but promise me
I'll never have to go back to work again
Adrian let me tell you something Adrian
when she said that
I was like yo E when you get home you
got to grind bro
you might have to start getting up at 2
30. you might might even go to sleep bro
legit I'm just saying I'm telling you I
never did this before I started looking
at my booking gigs I realized like I say
no to 750 to a thousand gigs a month
I started doing my homework yo I start
man I I was just with this dude got the
top podcast in the world and I started
doing my homework I had I paid a couple
people to do some homework for me I
called my man he's like yo E you ain't
operating off 10 of yo
he's like yo E for real bruh I've been
with the best don't nobody communicate
he like yo most dudes that I they can
only talk to one group E he like yo you
it'll make a different one age it don't
it'll make a difference with ethnic
background he like yo E you the greatest
communicator on the Earth right now you
only operating about 10 percent
I was like yo it's time to go to work
I'm telling you I've been thinking I've
been making calls that's what I'm asking
you to do what fuse you the reason why
you so lazy is not because you don't
have the ability you're so lazy because
your dream's so small yeah
your dreams are so small the Packers
last week they won the first quarter
what kind of game was it when we got to
the end what type of game was it it was
a close game right it was a close game
Cowboys had a chance to win that thing
it was a close game this game wasn't
what
it was a blowout it's a blowout why
because not only did the Falcons win the
first quarter not only did they win the
second quarter they were up 24-0 at the
half they dominated
I want to help some of you because some
of you in this room I don't want you
just to compete because competing is
dangerous because when you compete you
got to go all the way to the fourth
quarter to make that thing happen but
when you dominate pretty much when they
came back after the half it was pretty
much what
it was over and the thing that's cool
about dominating is when you dominate
you take your opponent out the game if
you line it up as a wide receiver you
kind of just like out there you're not
like oh let's go you kind of like uh
well we lost let's just see how many
points we can put on the board so we
just don't get shut out I am charging
you not to be a student not to be an
entrepreneur not to be whatever you are
I am charging you that in your space you
need to dominate in your space so in
Green Bay who just won last week come
back after the half they hold their
heart gone they like they checked Green
Bay came back and was like Rogers can't
even save us
we can't be saved all the Green Bay
Packer fans was at home I'm talking
about miserable
if you like Green Bay you like it's over
you was pacing around the house Atlanta
was off the charged everybody in Atlanta
was like rise up I'm getting text from
folks I didn't even know they from
Atlanta rise I thought you was from
Detroit I lived in Atlanta for six
months rise up right so I'm being real
you want last week we talked about yeah
we you want to finish the first quarter
you want to but now we're going to talk
about domination right I'm gonna show
you in a second what that looks like all
right so real quick anybody know who
this is
Serena good next one this is
all right good we there all right next
one
okay it's all right all right let's go
right quick yep yep yep and she beat
Serena
yeah let's go to the next one
who's that
okay let's stop so real quick now what I
got to explain to y'all is this they are
all Pros like these are people who have
beat Serena and Venus they're all right
you don't know who they are though they
probably won one or something they might
want one grand slam but two so they
professional they are Pros they getting
paid in the in the tennis world when
they walk out people like sign my ball
people like oh but you don't know them
why is it that you don't know them like
how you know Venus you don't know Venus
because you play tennis you know Venus
because there was a time in her career
she dominated and then her sister came
and she dominated that's why you know
who they are let me say this to you this
is what domination looks like Venus has
dominated in tennis and as a result
she's made 34 million dollars just in
tennis Serena has made 84 million
dollars just in tennis that's what
domination look like now when you go to
these young ladies it's like 8 million
that's a good salary but they don't make
what Serena and Venus make why they have
not dominated so who is this yeah LeBron
James yeah next one
yeah Steph Curry yup next one yeah yeah
somebody know but most of y'all like who
my man my man play for the Nuggets he
started here NBA Pro let's go to the
next one I know you know who this is
right here boom Dog Jazz he ain't in
there he not in the developmental League
he's not playing over Steve he's
starting with Utah you don't know him no
why because he not dominating so we're
gonna try not to compete we're gonna try
to do what come on we're gonna try not
to compete we're gonna try to do what I
need you to dominate I realize that you
know it's okay to look out for yourself
you know what I'm saying like like I put
in a lot of work for the world I bless
the world you know I'm saying if I stop
today I probably bless the world more
than the average human being is gonna
bless the world you know what I'm saying
and it's like the last you know however
many years I got like it's so it's okay
to go gorilla like it's okay to it's
okay to go beast mode yeah it's okay
yeah I'm just saying it's okay you know
what I'm saying I feel like for real I'm
at a point where I feel like God will
say to me today well done I'll go to
faithful serving like what I call you to
do yeah you you took it and you ran with
it but now I need you to look out for
you you know what I'm saying in a way
that nobody else is going to look out
for you because it's you you know and I
think when you do what I do you make the
you make the mistake when you're younger
of thinking you pouring all these people
they're just gonna automatically turn
around important to you and it don't
work like that not even in a bad way but
nobody even knows what you need first
and foremost no other human even knows
what you need they're not in you to know
what you need you know so they're just
certain opportunities that I would be
like nope I'm not gonna do that because
this is going to take me away from being
a servant and it's like yo you served
enough you know what I'm saying and I
look at I look at my mentor and that's
the one thing that that I'm hurt for is
like you know he will pass and have put
70 years in the blessing people and I
don't know if he ever got to do this I
don't know if he was ever able to rent
something out for a month and come and
enjoy the fruits of his life only if
only the if I was the only person that
he blessed yeah you know what I'm saying
he would have done a great work and he
never got to rest you know for years and
enjoy the fruits of his labor and I'm
like yo I'm not going out like that yeah
you know because if you if not in a bad
way but so many people are in need I
never forget that there was a scripture
where they was telling Jesus like we
didn't whatever whatever why are you
doing this and that and why you ain't
doing that he was like the poor will
always be among us you know what I'm
saying like I'm with the disciples right
now that's my focus and I realize now
the shift has to be from the masses you
know to a select group and my wife and
my kids and my mom right now is a part
of that you know so uh for me like I
always say it ain't like I I don't care
what the assessment said I'm from
Chicago and Detroit it ain't like I
don't got gorilla like you don't make it
on the streets of Detroit being soft you
know what I'm saying you don't you're
not homeless yeah yeah you're not you're
not homeless living in abandoned
building being soft yeah but I always
felt like I had to look out for others
first and I put myself second and I and
I don't have no regrets but I'm still
young and I still got a whole lot like
Serena said yesterday I ain't about to
retire no time soon my career is just
getting started and just watching you
Josh you know and just the things you've
exposed me to it's like e these next 30
go get these championships you know go
rack up their bank account go rack up
the houses Go Wrap rack up the trips you
know what I'm saying but again for those
of you who are listening who are your
others focused yo put in your work like
you want to lay down at the end of the
day because you are about others and you
need to go to sleep knowing that you
took care of it but at some point you
got to put a stop to that because LeBron
could have been in Cleveland for the
rest of his life he gave him a
championship he brought that City what
he what he needed to do in his heart he
brought that City that Championship now
I feel good that LeBron is going out and
LeBron's about to go to La and do movies
and put himself and his family in a
position where his legacy you gotta be
specific
you gotta say I'm gonna make
325
482 a year
exactly you can't be like I want to be
rich in the world like I don't know what
that is
[Music]
I don't know what rich is I don't know
what that means
are you hearing me I got a question for
you are you ready to play at this level
come on win you talk come on baby arm
City do you see it show them some b-roll
y'all
[Music]
play at this level I never asked you can
you play at this level I never asked you
that I know you can play at this level I
don't care what they told you I don't
care where you come from I don't care
what you've seen look you don't have to
do what your family did you you don't
have to accept the life that was given
to you I just got a question for you you
ready to play at this level you have
what it takes to play at this level but
the question is can you play at this
level do you have a heart do you know
how to perseverance do you had a
commitment do you have a consistency and
let me tell you something before I go
every house you see out here somebody
living in it and guess what they human
just like you so before I get out of
here E.T got a question for you are you
ready to play are you I'm sorry I should
have asked it first are you ready to
play at this level and if you wait and
play at this level
I'll see you on top so do me a favor
stop making excuses and make the rest of
your life the best of your life let's go
baby you ready to play at this level
let's go somebody asked me like yo E how
do you stay fired up bruh you've been
doing this since she was 19. it seemed
like damn me and Dad were there back me
and dad was talking he was like E I
listen to so many other motivational
speakers e and it just seemed like you
get better and better and I said I get
better and better because I the thing
that pumped me up in the beginning is
the thing I think about every day I wake
up every day like yo E you gotta take
control bro cause if you don't take
control we live in a society outside of
your house you live in a world full of
sharks
this world is run primarily by sharks
and I promise you if you don't become
one they will eat you alive
and something happens no matter who you
are if you're average or if you're good
when you get around greatness and you
stay around greatness you start
listening to Great podcasts and reading
great books and you start hanging around
great people when you start becoming a
part of great masterminds guys you just
evolve and I don't know what happened
but every year I went from a high school
dropout and homeless to I started to be
coming every single day more of who I am
and I can't believe it my next goal is
to win the Nobel Prize why I had to come
up with something listen to me you have
to be careful when you hang around
average people all they're going to do
is tell you what they can't do and
that's okay that they can't do it but
that has absolutely nothing to do with
us we can go from being homeless in high
school dropouts to having phds writing
books and becoming the voice of a
generation we can do whatever we believe
we can do and we don't need anybody's
permission to do it but ours you think
every gift comes right so yeah you did
it once yep you did it twice and it
didn't work out so you quit look every
gift don't come rap are you hear me yeah
you did it for three months yep you get
it for six months yeah and you like
where the results look it's called take
more than six months for what you trying
to do to become a react now I get it
yeah in math it comes easy to you so you
just think everything Gonna Come Easy
yeah I get it when you write you can
wait to the last minute and still
produce a great paper but you wonder why
you don't do well in math look every
gift don't come rap and just because it
don't come rap don't mean it ain't a
gift are you hearing what I'm saying
ever since I've been a kid I've been
able to speak but something happens when
I get in that booth and I do voice over
work it ain't as easy but it don't mean
it ain't a gift it does not mean that
God has not blessed me to be able to be
just as effective in voiceover as he has
getting in front of a crowd it just when
I stand in front of a crowd it's just
easier but when I get that booth and
it's a script when I get in that booth
and sometimes it's difficult to
enunciate work are you hearing what I'm
telling you just because it ain't gift
wrap don't mean it ain't a gift right
all gifts don't come gift wrap and you
gotta learn to stop starting and
stopping you got to learn to stop
quitting and giving up just because it
didn't work out for you the first time
just because it didn't work out the 20th
time just because it didn't work out the
30th time and every time I got in that
Booth I'm telling y'all I used to feel
embarrassed I would get in that booth
and the magic just wouldn't happen right
I couldn't just turn it on and turn it
off like the ET that I know the E.T
would just disappear in the booth but I
didn't quit I didn't give up just
because it wasn't gift wrap I kept going
and I kept going and I kept grinding and
listen to me very closely yeah you saw a
good year last game you want to know
what it takes to succeed as if you saw
me with the NFL you saw me get some
stuff with the NBA listen to me closely
you saw me do something for the Olympics
in dicks but let me tell you up I didn't
quit I just kept going and kept going
because what I know about life is you
can't lose you cannot lose if you do not
quit and I kept going and I kept going
and I kept practicing and I kept going
because every gift ain't gift wrapped
the biggest difference between you and
the people who you look up to are that
they started
and you're still thinking about it it's
one of the most frustrating things
in helping entrepreneurs that I deal
with on a day-to-day basis is that
seeing so much potential in people seen
so much heart and love and cares like
you you could be serving so much and
helping so much and having such a big
impact
and and we're stuck
we're stuck
and this was me too I was stuck it took
me forever to get started and I thought
I had to have the the perfect cameraman
my first video if you go back and watch
it on my channel I had my friend come
and film it and record it for me because
I was worried about it not being perfect
enough that I didn't know the gear and
didn't know the microphone and the
lighting and the setup and I I memorized
the script because I didn't want to say
the wrong words I had to be perfect uh
most of my early videos were were still
mostly voice over because I could write
a script and have it perfect and just
have b-roll and it wouldn't be me on
camera afraid of making a mistake and
saying the wrong things and messing up
and that's one of the main reasons why
it took me so long to grow you know if
you look at my journey of
making what for five years seven
thousand subscribers something like that
it was I was stuck I was I was
I was too afraid to do the next thing I
was too afraid to get in the race I was
making content at least I was one decent
thing for whatever reason I stay
consistent on on doing stuff but I was
afraid to take the next step the big
step to go off and do it and
a lot of you are already way better than
than I was when I started
and when I'm on interviews and I'm I'm
doing events and presentations and I see
the audience and I see who's there and I
see the skill and the and the heart just
the this is the thing that kills me the
most it's like the hearts like you want
you've got such a good heart you want to
do so much
and then there's just no action there's
no momentum because of the fear if you
could make one change
this year that would really move the
needle it would be to stop judging
yourself for the content that you're
making or the product you're putting out
or the service and just expect it to
suck and keep going
so when people ask me should I should I
do this business or this business should
I do that business or this one's like
well I don't know you know like at the
end of the day it's gonna be what you
love doing all of them could work
every business model can work and has
worked it's what's going to be the right
one for you and you won't know until
you get out there and start doing it
right it's like how do you know what
your favorite food is until you get out
there and do it how do you know if you
like coffee or not you know you have to
go off and you take a sip and then you
find out you can't think your way
through this so you can't think your way
you can have some planning but the
planning won't save you at the end of
the day you have to go off and just do
something about it and in the doing
you'll figure out
what makes you come alive and keep going
so
let's make it practical like let's give
you some steps for how to actually get
in the race and start taking some action
step one
understand
or at least tell yourself that great
ideas flow through you
great ideas flow through you that
because you came up with the idea that
it's a good idea stop judging and stop
telling yourself you suck stop telling
yourself someone like you can't do it
like great ideas flow through you this
is a good idea you need to go do
something about it right even just
telling yourself that shortcuts the fear
because all of the reasons in your head
for why you can't do it is really just
fear if you're thinking about making
content and you're worried about the
microphone and the camera and the gear
and all that that's just fear talking
it's just you're afraid that it won't be
good and so you're trying to cover your
bases and we come up with all these
logical reasons why we can't do it but
really it's just fear talking so cut
through the fear by telling yourself
that great ideas flow through you
that you don't want to be sitting here
three years later still stuck in the
same spot
right what's the difference well how
much action you took over those three
years and most of us are are stuck in an
action because we're Paralyzed by fear
and we've come up with rational reasons
why we can't do the thing so one great
ideas flow through you trust them and do
something about them two apply what I
call the two percent difference and so
most of the time what's the first thing
we do when we come with an idea when you
come up with an idea you think it's a
great idea you're going to start a
channel you're going to write a book
you're going to create this product
Service Company whatever you come up
with a great idea
the first thing we do is usually
planning right plan plan I need to plan
here's what my perfect world looks like
I'm going to plan all the way out and
what ends up happening is you spend your
best energy planning the first step in
my opinion should not be planning the
first step should be some kind of
imperfect action because what ends up
happening is you get all this energy and
motivation and you feel like you're
unstoppable and you can do it this is
such a good idea
and then you start spending your time
planning and researching what is up
happening is you wake up the next day
and the next day and your energy and
your belief starts to drop it's like oh
what was I thinking I can't do that who
am I to do that the doubts and
insecurities and the fears all start to
pop in and so you you stop
and nothing ends up happening besides a
list of ideas and you're planning and
research but that doesn't that doesn't
get you paid that doesn't get the
service out there doesn't actually help
anybody and so
planning is important it just shouldn't
be the first step the first step should
be some kind of imperfect action just
start doing something anything you you
want to make a YouTube channel great
pull out your phone and make a video
what do you see in the video it doesn't
matter just speak from the heart like
hey I want to start a YouTube channel
I've been thinking about doing this for
a bunch of years and I've always been
too afraid and now I've decided that I'm
going to go off and do it and I don't
know what I'm going to talk about I'm
just going to do my best
and hopefully you'll support me alright
see you soon post there's your video was
it great no but it's everything because
you you started doing something you
think about a fitness plan that people
are going on
what are people normally do on a fitness
plan well you you're researching all do
I do CrossFit do I do weights do I do
cardio do I do Zumba do I do salsa
dancing and you're so caught up we all
get this we all get so caught up in what
the perfect plan is that we never
actually do anything we're the the best
thing you can do is go and do 10
push-ups right now or five or two
however many you can do are those two
push-ups gonna make any difference
for the long-term health no I mean no
you're not building muscle from two
push-ups obviously but the moment the
act of momentum is the thing that
matters because in doing the two
push-ups maybe tomorrow you do four the
next day you do six and actually you do
eight and you're starting to build the
habit of somebody who does push-ups that
then can lead you to do more research to
find out oh I was doing the push-ups all
wrong
here's a better way to do it or I should
be doing this instead you'll learn as
you go and the research in the plan is
important it just can't be the first
step so step one again is expect that
great ideas flow through you that that
idea that came to you is good is worthy
you should do it you should at least try
it set number two is two percent
difference what that means is
don't plan to get the hundred percent
for a focus on the first two percent
most of us will plan to figure out what
the 100 looks like you won't know what's
the first two percent you can take
action on right now and just go do it
and then step three is just expect a
suck at the beginning
we expect we don't expect to be great at
the start but we expect to be good we
expect to be at least average at the
start of whatever we do we never think
it's going to be easy I mean some people
do I guess but for the most part you
don't think whatever you're getting into
is going to be easy but you don't expect
it to be as hard as it is and you don't
expect to be as bad as you are at the
thing and it doesn't mean that you're
bad as a human it just means that you're
bad at the skill
and so how do you get skills well by by
practicing by doing it by training right
and so you're going to be way worse
than you thought you would be at the
beginning that's okay you just don't
have the skill yet so I go into any new
thing expecting to suck just completely
expect to suck expected to be a total
failure and if it's not then great and
every day you get up and you do it again
you'll be a little bit better and you'll
suck a little bit less because you're
developing the skills you can get really
really good at something if you have
passion energy and your pouring time
into actually improving at it where most
people
will just make one thing
see how much it sucks and then never go
back to it so just expect it to be
terrible at the beginning
don't worry so much about how much of a
failure that first one was and then you
keep going keep you make another one
tomorrow and another one tomorrow
another tomorrow and you will get better
if you follow that process this is this
is how you actually start becoming the
person who you want to be you start
getting the results and the impact that
you want to have
you've got the heart and the talent and
and the the abilities and the care
the difference is just there's no
momentum where there's not enough
momentum for what you're capable of and
so if you follow those three steps right
great ideas flow through you believe it
follow the two percent difference
instead of planning research and do
something you need action and then three
expect to suck and keep going
you get that momentum you need start
changing your life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
of Eric Thomas's best speeches of all
time check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there many of
you are taking anything and you don't
know what you want and so if I can do
one thing for you when you leave this
room I don't want nothing from you but
for you to leave this room and know what
you want what do you want in your
marriage what do you want